[Musique]
les images ont fait le tour du monde
comme celle-ci et celle-ci ou encore
celle-ci autant d'incidents à caractère
raciste qui vise Vénissieux encore
dimanche l'attaquant Brésilien aurait
été traité de singes par des partisans
adverses lors d'un match du Real Madrid
à Valence ce n'était pas la première la
deuxième ni même la troisième fois a
écrit Vinicius sur les réseaux sociaux
le racisme est normal dans la Ligue
espagnole ce beau pays que j'aime et qui
m'a accueilli accepte aujourd'hui
d'exporter l'image d'un pays raciste la
police espagnole a arrêté trois
personnes après les incidents avalanche
et 4 autres en lien avec la pendaison du
néphigie de Vénissieux survenu à Madrid
en janvier dernier pour l'analyse
Hassoun Camara les joueurs n'ont plus le
choix ils doivent quitter le terrain
dans ces circonstances je parle pas
seulement des joueurs noirs c'est le
point que je voulais donner aussi je
pense que l'ensemble des joueurs peu
importe la couleur de peau peu importe
le maillot porté les joueurs opposés
aussi doivent prendre la décision
unanime de sortir et dimanche
l'entraîneur du Real Madrid Carlo
Ancelotti ne voulait pas parler de
soccer
un sentiment que peut comprendre
l'entraîneur du CF Montréal Hernan
lassada
l'entourage de Vinicius songeait
maintenant à lui trouver un autre club
dès cet été de quoi faire réfléchir les
responsables du championnat espagnol que
le joueur accuse de minimiser la
situation ici Olivier Tremblay
Radio-Canada Montréal